[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys and
welcome back to the leia hile pen show
powered by
icon plus so i want to give a really
quick um shout out to them actually
because
icon plus if you guys didn't know so
they're actually a public representative
um for the icon network they've been
doing a lot of pr and marketing
um and a lot of us wouldn't know who
iphone network were without um
icon classes hard work so if you do
stake your ics tokens then definitely
vote for icon plus
um i also want to say a quick thank you
to my sponsors block fi
so i use them to earn up to 8.6 interest
on my uscc if you don't know
uscc is a stable coin which is pegged to
the us dollar
um i feel like this is going over
people's heads so this is eight point
six percent interest is pretty insane
given
interest rates are practically
practically flat i can't get my words
out
um and across europe we've seen negative
interest rates so
that's eight point six percent and on
bitcoin you get around six percent
that's pretty cool
um and just finally before we talk
bitcoin and everything else that's going
on
um i wanna say another shout out to
coinflip um so
they are doing amazing works um they
have over
1 000 atms across the states bringing
bitcoin mass adoption
to a lot of different people so i think
that's fantastic i do have a discount
code um
you can get 10 off their off their
transactions so i'll leave that code for
you guys somewhere in the comments
um but i want to get started today we
have a really cool guest somebody who's
an absolute expert on everything bitcoin
everything crypto so i'm gonna bring him
in it is matty greenspan what's up matty
how's it going leia nice to see you
it's good to see you too how is
everything i love the 20k
in the background there we go yeah i
think you're good i can't complain
i'm not going to ask you is it going to
happen yet i want to delve into you
before we caught in the market
yeah i mean you're always super better
anybody following me on twitter knows
knows my opinion about this yeah i know
i know we're gonna go into all of this
but for those that don't know a little
bit about you you were previously at
etoro
um so you are obviously an absolute
expert in this market in this space
so tell us a little bit about that and
you've now founded quantum economics i
think at the beginning of this year was
it
yeah november it's it's uh a year ago i
left etoro
and started quantum economics uh two
days later
um i my name is matthew greenspan i am a
uh
i was the senior market analyst in etoro
now the founder of quantum economics the
co-author of the book the complete guide
to fintech investing in a licensed money
manager
in the european union that's that's me
that's you okay so i obviously want to
talk about the market
um but before we get there you know i
kind of want to understand why we're
here
um you know we often talk about this
issue with traditional finance
but i don't feel like that idea and that
real issue
is kind of understood enough um even in
this even in this community you know
we're all sort of like oh inflation
there's printing money that but
we don't really sort of go into it so if
you could
say the top three issues you think there
are
with that there is with the traditional
financial system what would that be
well just three huh well you can give me
all of them
don't hold back matty well i
i think that one of the main issues um
is that we live in in mostly in in
democracies
these days um but the people who control
the money actually the central banks
they control the supply of money and
they
they control interest rates are actually
not democratically elected
and then they're able to make unilateral
decisions that affect everyone
um sometimes this can be a good thing
and sometimes
not so great of course i mean there is
something to be said
for you know um dictatorship
i think that dictatorships often run
smoother than democracies in in many
cases
um and you know and if there's an
emergency
we can see that it functions certainly
better than
uh traditional government and in case in
point right now where we're seeing that
the fed is able to act however they like
however they feel is needed however they
feel they feel the economy
uh requires but congress is not right
and that's actually what
what needs to happen at the moment is uh
is stimulus from congress there's two
different types of stimulus that
everybody needs to know about there's
monetary stimulus which is from the
central banks
basically the central bank's pumping
money into the banking system
and fiscal stimulus actually comes from
the government
itself right and at the moment monetary
stimulus is abundant the central banks
are able to pump as much as they like
but the fiscal stimulus is harder
because it requires agreement
between the different parties democrats
and the republicans they are not getting
along right now whatsoever and therefore
they're not able to provide that fiscal
stimulus
those stimulus checks that we saw one
thousand two hundred dollars
i think it was back in april everybody
was expecting it to happen again
but because congress can't get together
the republicans and the democrats are
deadlocked
uh and therefore it's not happening and
the fed just over the last
two days we saw both jerome powell
and steven mnuchin who's the treasury
secretary in the white house
um begging congress like practically
they could be like getting down on their
knees they might as well be getting down
on their knees right now
please congress just write a check just
write a check and all congress needs to
do is say okay here's the check here's
the amount
it's not like a big fundamental flaw i
mean there isn't like everybody agrees
it needs to be done
but nobody wants to be seen as the one
who's buckling to the other side
um and everybody's trying to get their
little tiny um
it's really an issue of pride more than
anything like everybody knows
stimulus checks need to happen you can't
take away people's jobs tell them you're
not allowed to work it's illegal for you
to go to work
and then not provide them something to
be able to pay the bills and feed their
families at the end of the day so what's
happening i think
um is a sham and um
yeah i i i think that that's fine people
they need to wear a mask in public
okay fine i don't i think it's a bit
overkill but if
if you want to go for it right and then
tell people um
you know okay so uh you need to have up
to
five people in in a in a hundred square
meter store or 50 square meter store
whatever it is
is the mandate fine people can wait
outside in a line
i don't care but telling people that
they're from a certain industry and
therefore
they can't work and not not providing
any type of stimulus i mean
it's really i mean we're we're
we're we've taken something that could
have been rather trivial and making it
into
something that's a multi-generational
issue
what is it you mean covet or you mean
this stimulus are you talking the
monetary system
which bit right well all of it together
i suppose i mean
kovit you know it is it is a problem
and i do know people who've contracted
covet and people who've died from it and
it sucks but um at the end of the day
uh the damage that's being done to the
economy right now
is f is far outweighing that and i
believe that
um
the government is in a position that
they can rectify it somewhat
but they're refusing to and over silly
reasons
yeah i mean i i mean it kind of just
shocks me i feel like there's so many
things that we're not allowed to talk
about
and we're sort of not allowed to talk
about the fact that you know there's
that 99.9
survival rate and if you're those are
those your kids in the background
very cute um yes sorry no worries it's
okay
and you know if you're over i think over
70 it's around 94
survival rates so i would definitely say
there's a huge overreach
um i mean if you're going to stop people
from working then
of course you're going to have to sort
of that's your responsibility you have
to sort of make up for that financially
um but you know i just say just let
people work you know i think
it's pretty interesting the way um you
know
a lot of the time in life in in society
we have the freedom to decide how much
risk that we want to take
but it's kind of odd in this situation
we're not allowed to decide how much
risk we want to take you know
smoking kills you but we are within our
right to take that risk
you know you can die getting on a
getting on a plane you can die by
driving
um you know but we're within our rights
to take that risk um
you know as a woman i could get attacked
by getting it you know walking alone at
night
um but it's not illegal to do that um i
just know you know
i can weigh up my wrist i can say okay
well you know i'm small i'm very small
actually in real life
um you know i'm where you can take
karate i mean yeah
you know and you defend yourself that's
your decision to make
exactly but given i know that i'm at
risk i wouldn't walk through a dark park
on my own at night so
we have that freedom to decide you know
how much risk we want to take
it kind of surprised i don't know if it
surprises me i just don't know why we're
not following through
um you know when it comes to this
yeah it is a bit bamboozling and but
to to to your question i mean what are
the the the flaws within the financial
system i mean
this is an apparent a blatant one where
you know congress is not able to provide
stimulus
are
guys while matty speaks to his little
ones um
i just want to also let you know we're
doing more intense negotiations here
you're an intense negotiation so that's
fine i'll i'll i'll chat to my i'll chat
to my audience so i just want to thank
you guys all so much for tuning in
um i can see that we have um we have
matthew that's tuned in thank you so
much we've got blockchain monkeys who
says this is a great show
so thank you so much nebula is here
jason williams is here who now
identifies apparently um as a big
chocolate man
that's what jason williams
he's yeah identified as a big chocolate
man which is which is interesting
because he's quite the opposite
are you still in intense negotiations or
do we have you matty
yes um we have you we're i'm back
you're back cool okay right i want to
talk about the financial system i want
to know the problem
um you said you know it's undemocratic
which is pretty interesting you know
they get to make these decisions like
printing x amount of money we never
voted um to allow that to happen
um but other than on it being
undemocratic
tell me more of the problems something
so simple that i can turn around to my
friends
and say these are the problems this is
why you need to be encrypted this is why
you need bitcoin
sure so the sim the simple fact of the
matter is
that fiat currency or currency that is
unbacked and created uh unilaterally by
governments
is designed intentionally to depreciate
over time
um you'll see that the central banker is
talking about
uh inflation as if uh the lack of
inflation is is a criminal thing or a
very bad thing that needs to be
rectified
right they say okay we're not you know
um we need to get to two percent
inflation we need to
we need to have more inflation we need
to have more inflation meaning
what what they what they're saying is i
mean very clearly
is that we need to devalue the money
that's in your bank account
right it sounds absurd but why
but that's what's happening um
there are many reasons for it and then
there could be you know uh there are
cases to be made
why inflation can be a good thing for
economy for an economy
um for the most part it pushes people
towards consumerism
right if you know that the money in your
bank account is going to be worth
less in five years you're less likely to
save it and more likely to spend it
i find that so sickening like that's so
sickening like there's nothing
um that's kind of like um it's not like
it's not a positive thing it's kind of
holding you hostage isn't it it's kind
of blackmailing you
yeah it's incredible it's it's slavery
to consumerism it's what's been
happening for
last several decades at least yeah i
mean it it just blows my mind you know
because people celebrate quantitative
easing
and they sort of say yeah you know it
stimulates the economy it gets people to
spend
but but it's absolute blackmail in my
opinion there's nothing positive it's
like hang on i don't want to spend
you know we spend too much black friday
is stupid we spend way
too much you know we don't need all of
these things and i was watching a
documentary recently about minimalism
not that i'm into minimalism that much
to be honest but you know
i mean there's something to be said
about having too much stuff and people
sort of
buying um to find happiness in these
things but it's really empty
i want to talk about inflation though
because our inflation rates that we see
in the west you're obviously in the
middle east
um you know it's not what we see in
countries like venezuela for example
right um and so when i often put forward
this argument about inflation people are
just like no
you know this is normal this is natural
inflation rates whatever that means
so we don't see hyperinflation so
despite not seeing any hyperinflation
here would you still see
say you know inflation is actually an
issue
that is a good question and um because
covet 19 is completely uh screwed
with all of the barometers that we have
to understand the economy
um we have to understand what's
happening here so first of all within
the first two months of
the covet 19 lockdowns uh more
money had been injected into the
american economy than had been
in the first 200 years
of america's existence um
now a logical person would say okay
more money supply therefore you know
supply and demand therefore the demand
on the currency goes down and the
value of the currency goes down um
but economists are very quickly finding
that this isn't always the case and
over the last 10 years we've seen them
testing
pushing the limits more further and
further how much can we print
um and not have inflation
and what they're really seem to be
scared about is deflation
right where the god forbid the people
the money in people's bank accounts
should actually
increase in value over time um
why don't they want them why would they
be scared
it's bad for it's bad for business
people people end up saving rather than
spending
okay so it's the opposite what we were
just saying okay i'm with you exactly
um so generally so generally speaking
i mean inflation isn't isn't all
all that like a bad thing but the
problem is when
um they continued to they continued to
push this money in and because because
of covet 19 now we see
um all of a sudden people aren't
spending anyways
right so because people aren't spending
um there we don't see any kind of
movement in the economy and therefore
inflation cannot happen inflation can
only really happen
once we see the velocity pick up where
money is actually changing hands on a
regular basis
that's when inflation occurs so right
now what we're seeing is basically
um imagine like uh a punch uh a punch
uh jug of punch or whatever right you
have the powder and you mix in all the
powder
and um so they've been stirring right
and then
they put the they put the powder in and
they you know they see the powder just
keeps dripping down to the bottom right
and then now we have a situation where
and rather than rather than stirring it
up
and making the powder move around the
jug they just keep pouring
more powder in right and now you have a
jug that's like half powder and half
this uh kind of
a mush but you know that once people go
back to work right eventually we hope
that
you know those lockdowns will be over
and people are going to go out and spend
again they're going to go travel and
they're going to go on vacation and
they're going to go
uh and get back to their to normal lives
that's when things get stirred up and
this is
bad and that's when things can
potentially get very nasty because we
have all of that
excess powder in the bottom once things
get stirred around it's going to be
really uh
okay i don't know yeah interesting so
just to like clarify that so for
inflation to sort of happen and take
place the
money needs to be spent so right now
we're not going to see the effects
because everything's shut down we're not
spending
but then once everything starts going
back into circulation that makes sense
that makes perfect sense once everything
go back into circulation that's when
we're going to see it essentially
yeah very likely this is what economists
are expecting but
uh the more the more we learn the more
we realize that our previous assumptions
are are simply moot and and
unreliable okay
so speaking of deflationary assets let's
talk about bitcoin
um you're new on the overall markets
right now so i want to
talk about your view on bitcoin firstly
do you think that it's performed well
this year um i'm obviously going to get
on to
what's happening right now you know at
the beginning of the ball round but
let's just talk about 2020 you know i
i've been reading that the dollars down
um bitcoin's clearly not so so what are
your thoughts on bitcoin this year
yeah i mean bitcoin has consistently
been an out performer of of everything
in the world
yeah i mean we've seen it
since it's it's since its creation
basically i mean there have been very
few
years when it hasn't outperformed every
other financial asset on the planet
yeah and at the beginning of this year
my prediction was the same it was
exactly they asked me for a comment on
and i said that this is
look this is how it's done there's
little reason to suspect that it
won't do that again um and therefore you
know obviously the bulk of my
investments
uh right now at this moment and time are
in bitcoin
um with of course uh fail states
involved because you know sometimes we
get those 20 30 percent corrections
what kind of fell interest
um well we've got these big monitors up
make sure that uh
we don't uh we don't cross any of those
red lines if we do
then we cut exposure a little bit what
red light um
what would be red light for you um
10k line or yes
i would say 10k i don't think that look
i think that there's a real possibility
that we'll never see
uh bitcoin below 10 000 ever again
um but if you want to pull up the chart
we've got a few lines of support
coming up here
pull that up let's have a look can we
see it
okay that's it we're getting live uh
we're getting a live ta here this is fab
all right 10k right there's
there is that is an ultimate level of
support as far as i see
uh 12k 14k and then 16k but i think 16th
favorite they're probably going to get
to 16 and
a half i think it's more relevant and a
half was was
um but the fun thing here is
that every single these were these lines
had never existed previously
right because the first time we went
from 10k to 20k
come back come back they say the first
time that we went from 10k to 20k
we went up so fast to two weeks and we
came back down so fast
that the charts didn't have enough time
to build up proper support and
resistance lines
but now we've seen that they did and we
can see that the way that they
interacted with these levels so 10k
if you'll recall um it took a while
for it to test this right i mean look at
look at it testing here
testing here testing here testing here
once it did that
once it did break through it blasted
through and it didn't just go through it
and went all the way up to 12k before it
was 20
before even slowing down and stopping
and we can see 12k the same same thing
it tested here
retraced critical that it pulled back
and tested that 10k
as a support level right and then we can
see once it got back to that 12k it
blasted through
right now and then got all the way up to
14k
before pulling back ever so slightly we
didn't ever get a test of 12k
level which i would have liked to see
but didn't come a bit closer again come
a bit closer again
yeah i said we could i wish we would
have
tested that 12k again as a support but
we didn't okay
okay and then 16 and a half we blasted
through 16 and a half we have now tested
as a support level
right now things can come if things do
get ugly they turn around right now and
it would be a shame certainly to
to come all this way and not see that
level of 10 of 20k
um but you know these are markets and
things happen
uh so then we have all of these levels
as valid support levels on the way down
meaning that we can take a
16 and a half now we can take 14 and we
can take 12 and we can see those
as excellent opportunities to add to
your position
i believe in my opinion anyways um
now the question is what happens at 20k
right
do we do we behave the same way as we
did with 10k
test it for a while test it again test
it again and then blast right through
if that happens i mean the sky is the
limit right
i don't see i don't see there's after
that there are no you know just as we
were before
uh once we're in all-time high territory
there are no
marks of resistance so we can go
100k a million 2 million 5 million who
knows
like the millions yes because
of digital scarcity and people people
miss this and
you know i'm you know certainly you know
there have been people who've picked
higher numbers than me i'm sure and
i i'm very hesitant to make any kind of
final call
um certainly at 80k i'll be ready to
take some profits
right yes i agree um but
what people don't understand is that the
charts don't always matter
right this is um you know as a
licensed portfolio manager every time we
talk about the charts
the regulator says you need to add the
disclaimer past performance does not
indicate future results okay
and it's very true when you're looking
at charts what you're seeing is past
performance and we can't
make any type of uh forward-looking
statements based on
based on history we can only say that
history has a tendency to repeat itself
um and those price levels are now
relevant
we can't necessarily say what will
happen once the relevant price levels
are reached
um so be that as it may
the charts are not necessarily what's
important here what's important
here are the fundamentals or actually
how many bitcoin are available
are available on the market for purchase
right
and what we saw in 2017 was there was
none
like we had times when people were
trying to buy and they could not at
any price get them right
and when you're in a situation where you
cannot get them at any price
and people still want still have the
desire to purchase
then the price goes up very very quickly
right because the buyer is then forced
to
raise his buying price until he gets
uh somebody who goes okay you know what
for that price i'll sell it to you
right um and this is why again
we can analyze the charts all we want um
and many will
but at the end of the day what what's
really at play here
is this uh ingenious design by satoshi
nakamoto
um with of implementing a hard cap at 21
million
uh and then that's it there isn't any
more
yeah my gosh i mean it's so insane
when we you know when you pull out those
numbers and we're also
you know i'm also in a world where
people can't even understand why bitcoin
matters and you know
even saying that bitcoin has a use case
whether that's as a store of value or
whatever it is people are often just
like you know it's a ponzi scheme it's a
pump and dump it's this and that
um so yeah it's super insane to hear
that um
okay so so you know you mentioned them
as like let's just say one million okay
let's just play with this number for a
second
if it was to reach something like that
even on its way up to something like
that
what does bitcoin really need to be
right like does it need to be a payments
system does it need to be um just as a
store of value
um does it you know does it have to just
be digital gold
obviously you know we know it doesn't
work fantastically well as
a payment system just given you know it
takes so long it's expensive
are you kidding me no tell me tell me
go on okay
out of the 14 members of quantum
economics
uh 10 of them would prefer to receive a
payment in bitcoin
yeah and myself 100 it's not only that
i i find it constantly like a constant
struggle i'll tell my bank
and i have i i have a very good bank and
they
give me a very great service is that an
israeli out of interest
no morgan stanley they get
they give me a very good service where i
have a dedicated account manager and i
tell them okay i want to transfer here's
the digits
here's the num here's the bank account
that i want to transfer to and then come
back to me
we couldn't find it or um the payment
was returned
i don't know why but i i waited two
business days
to figure out that the the payment
didn't go through yeah
and and at that point i just go to go
okay give me your btc address
he has it in 10 minutes
this happens to me over and over and
over again
right so as a means of payment it's
already way ahead of of
the the banking system yeah absolutely
agree with you it is way ahead of the
banking system but just in terms of i
don't know other potential
cryptocurrencies even if it's stable
coins i don't know
whatever it is or i mean a lot of them
just work
a lot faster um i think it's nano that
does it in seconds
so you know do you think that bitcoin
could become
that global payments i don't know
you know replace the dollar as that
global payment um like solution or do
you think
you know we're not gonna get that my
opinion on this is
less relevant only because while i'm i'm
on the show with you
actually just before that i took a
hiatus from writing my daily
quantum economics newsletter um
yesterday we highlighted uh larry fink
who is the ceo of blackrock
and blackrock for those of you don't
know is the largest money manager in the
world they have seven
uh point something trillion dollars
under management
they're the personal piggy bank also of
the federal reserve their
uh kind of liquidity provider for them
um
one of the main benefactors of course of
the last 10 years of quantitative easing
and uh larry fink
uh and this is what i'm writing about
today because yesterday i was so excited
about the announcement today i actually
went in and analyzed what did he say
and i'll be publishing it in just a bit
but he actually
questioned he he brought the question
can bitcoin or something like it
uh replace the us dollar as
the global reserve currency think about
it i mean this is something that you
know in 2011 you know
visionaries like you know charlie lee
and vitalik buterian you know yoneyasi
and
um you know many several others i mean
not very many people at that time we're
talking about
right we can have tokenized assets that
are on a blockchain and they're superior
to traditional assets
in less than 10 years that idea has now
propagated to
the highest bank in all of the land the
number one runner of money
of of private equity in the entire world
is now talking about this
future
hello leia's daddy's good friend
hello no hellos okay well we're going to
talk
let's go oh of course sorry
okay that makes sense okay so yeah i
mean absolutely the sentiment has
completely changed um over the last 10
years
to even have these kind of um questions
um
it is pretty insane so in terms of you
know bitcoin is moving right now i think
it's around
19.2 or 19.3 um
where do you where do you expect it to
go i know we've obviously mentioned
there's been a lot of support but
are you expecting a correction anytime
soon um
you know we're sort of testing new highs
um
what what do you expect for 2021
yeah i get and again you know
in the um there i yeah look because i i
i like this as a round number and um i
believe that it is extremely possible
uh any day now i mean we could we could
reach it
but again you know this is um
uh it's it's impossible to tell the
future leia i mean i i'm i wouldn't be
i wouldn't i mean i wouldn't be a very
good asset manager if i tried to do that
no good and i respect that i can't stand
you know when we're always hearing like
it's gonna like you know
we're gonna reach this price on this day
i mean we just don't know i think
overall you know there's a bullish
sentiment
you know we believe in the asset we
understand um the fundamentals behind it
and i guess
that's kind of all you can do um but you
know in terms of being this global
currency
it would need to scale right um so do
you think bitcoin can scale i know
there's the lightning network
but that's kind of not very
user-friendly what are your thoughts on
this
right so yeah the lightning network
i think is a failed experiment there's
they've taken them a very long time
uh to come to that uh realization but i
think even the people who are behind it
by now are starting to understand that
it's not it's not moving very fast
or it's it's come to a kind of a
roadblock i think that even
uh according to the latest uh the latest
uh reports that i saw
um there's more bitcoin on on the
ethereum network than there is in the
lightning network
um i do believe very uh very strongly in
the power of uh
stable coins um i think that and
especially with
uh the excellent work from brian brooks
uh where he's basically um
legitimized uh the entire industry of
stable coins
so basically we're gonna see kind of a
digitization of the us dollar not
as a central bank digital currency but
as the way that uh
currencies are today um you know
the commercial banks are the ones that
print dollars they're the ones who
create the dollars right
based on the reserves of the central
bank they can lend out
uh multiple times on every single dollar
so for every dollar in the federal
reserve
they can then lend out uh 10 times now
infinity times because there isn't any
kind of
um fractional or minimum fractional
requirement
um so at the end of the day but
but the inherent problem with that is
that um
you know you get you get to a point
where uh
there's contagion in the system right
meaning
that the the dollars printed at
jpmorgan are equal exactly to the
dollars printed at wells fargo
and jp morgan is obviously a much more
sound
and stable financial institution whereas
you know wells fargo has their issues
right um so when we get to the point
where jp morgan is able to
to print jpmorgan dollars and wells
fargo is able to print wells fargo
dollars
then we can see that there's um you know
the
the market can react to those
differently and then if something
happens to wells fargo
something happens to their dollars and
not to the us dollar which is
which can bring top of the entire system
i think that's extremely healthy for the
system
and um in many ways even greater than
what china's working on with their
central bank digital currency is to
let the corporate world lead um as they
always do
uh within the us economy and they think
that that's that's true capitalism and i
think that that's what's going to
end up prevailing at the end of the day
yeah so this
kind of brings me onto a really
interesting point actually um about
cbdc's
um and versus cryptocurrencies right
because they're obviously not exactly
the same thing
um so as we move forward right and we
move towards this lot of digital money
we're already hearing like you said you
know china and their cbdc
so in my opinion i feel like there's
going to be this tug of war between the
two
um you know you know you're talking
about bitcoin potentially as this global
currency so
do you think we're going to see a tug of
war do you think they could actually
work simultaneously
um the same way cash and you know right
now
sort of i guess digital money sort of
work simultaneously albeit they are on
the same side they're the same thing
um you know do you think we're gonna see
like a tug of war between the two like
the government and the freedom
movement or how do you see it playing
out
i'm not really sure how what what you're
what you're asking okay so we're moving
forward right with cryptocurrencies
and we're talking about cryptocurrencies
potentially being um
this global currency that everybody's
using you know
you're obviously a fan of stable coins
that you said um you're paying people in
bitcoin
but meanwhile governments are creating
their own cbdc's
so in my opinion digital money
is inevitable everything's going digital
you know the way
we socialize is digital the way we work
is digital dating is digital eating is
digital you know
everything is digital so it only makes
sense that money will become digital
but will it be the government's version
of crypto right like the cbdc's or will
it be our version of crypto
do you think they can work side by side
or do you think there'll be a tug of war
between the two
in terms of being that global currency
that everybody uses
right so i think that there is um it's
going to be very interesting how it how
it will play out
um at this point i see it kind of as
like you know a game of pickup sticks
where you've got the bundle and then you
just
drop it i mean to say exactly how it's
going to play out here would be very
difficult
we can kind of hypothesize right um in
my view
um you know china has come out with
their centralized
cbdc um the united states is coming out
with a very
decentralized system for digitizing the
us dollar
um and i i don't i don't know if that's
going to play in in the power dynamics
or affect the
us dollars uh ability to perform as the
as the global reserve currency i think
that the
banks will be able to innovate fast
enough to thwart off
uh the advances of china i think they
will be
um what you have in europe on the other
hand is something very different where
they're coming out with it seems
well they're still you know back and
forth and of course uh christine lagarde
was very likely put in in her position
as the european
uh central bank boss simply because of
her
her thoughts on digital currency
um there's a there's a very
they have they have a paradox right
because
they want to uh upgrade the system
and it's very clear that it's there are
benefits of that
but in the other hand um they have
uh issues of privacy right
um corporate structure in the united
states as we see you know each each bank
will be able to
uh protect the privacy of their
customers
at different levels right so some banks
will be able to offer privacy as a
feature
and might attract customers based on
that feature right similar to the way
apple is
doing now they say okay this is the
privacy phone the government can't get
your
can't get access to it uh so i believe
that there will be banks to say okay
your dollars that you're holding are
very private
um in europe it seems like they're
trying to come out with a centralized
system
um but also try to maintain privacy and
this is going to be
extremely difficult to do from a
technical perspective
um in europe and this is where my life
my financial license is from europe i've
seen it firsthand their compliance is
like
especially with anti-money laundering
laws they're so afraid that terrorists
might actually
get money into the system and buy things
with it that they actually just like
uh they refuse a lot of legitimate
business based on that
um and i think that
they're gonna find it very difficult to
have their cake and need it too
like how can you on the one hand crack
down on
on money laundering and tax evasion and
all of those things that you're afraid
of and on the same at the same time
protect the privacy of your citizens
the working paper that i read which came
out a few months ago
uh was that they're going to say okay
um for large you know for small
transactions and each person will be
entitled to
a certain amount of privacy credits
where you can make small
transactions that are fly underneath the
radar and are completely private and
nobody will understand but for larger
purchases
uh they'll be reported by young to the
government so that's almost like saying
okay so
um you can have your bedroom okay you
can do whatever you want in your bedroom
but we're gonna have to install a camera
in your living room for your own
protection
right so to be this like i it doesn't
there's not a solution i think that
they're gonna they're gonna find this
paradox extremely difficult to solve
yeah no i'm chasing with you and i think
you know seeing how those
different sort of i guess power side
power plays play out i think
will be really will be really
interesting but just on a final note
then regulation is something i just
quickly wanted to go over with you
um it's something that we're talking a
lot about at the moment um paypal
um their ceo are calling for the
community to
um to work hand-in-hand with regulators
which i think is
quite funny um so what are your thoughts
you know
is regulation the good old necessary
evil um can you even regulate bitcoin or
is it gonna be you know regulating the
on our end
you know um in terms of i don't know
making it making it you know kind of i'm
trying to think of something my head
what
we could do you know make it clear how
much you hold and who you're transacting
with and
and having to fill out papers and this
and i don't know
i mean can you regulate it right and
this just kind of
goes along the lines of what uh you know
what ray dalio was asking about which i
i covered in the
newsletter uh last week because he he
asked some very good questions about
bitcoin so why can't you know if it gets
too big why wouldn't
the government ban it um the simple
answer is they can't
um because you know it's a peer-to-peer
uh system and uh
technically it would be very difficult
even if they would
uh pour all of their resources into it
and
collaborate with several countries it
would be extremely difficult
if they did if that was the level i
think that bitcoin would have a a very
big
fight right there there would be
challenges um
but at the la at present time we we
don't really see that
push from governments and um
as far as you know in 2017 we had right
there was during that time there was the
fear and then there was the government's
going okay
with the exception of brad sherman i
don't think that anybody in in
the united states government really
wants to outlaw bitcoin at this point
right um you know we saw those tweets
from brian armstrong about
mnuchin and the the personal custody
wallets and stuff like that
um i think that that was there might
have been an idea floated
in passing that brian was responding to
and he's correct to respond to because
when there are bad ideas you you know
the industry needs to rise up and say
this is a bad idea because xyz just as
brian had done
i don't think that he had an intention
to crash the
the price or anything like that although
you know we never know
um but at the end of the day
we can see that the government is and
and
it seems to me even those laws that he
was responding to
were proposed uh in favor
of the currency without understanding
the
my new details but they actually
understood that okay there is something
here that we can uh that we should be
watching
and we should do something about and
then they proposed something this is
just about that that's just a bad idea
and now that
now that that has happened they of
course they left it alone if the
community on the other hand if the
community would have said hey
that's a great idea right uh maybe there
would have been a different reaction to
those
proposals and uh something could have
gone through
and again in a deadlocked congress right
now and nothing's going to go through so
it's really a
moot point but it's still important to
debate the ins and outs
yeah i just think it's interesting
because that was that whole conversation
as well with
um raul powell and you know he was sort
of saying regulation will
happen and you know you will still use
bitcoin
um you know do you think it's such an
inevitable thing though
in the way that he does or are you just
sort of very much on the lines of you
know the community were rejected like
you just said
and it's also physically not quite
possible
yeah i mean the thing about
cryptocurrencies and it's giving
regulators a real
run for their money because um
regulators are used to dealing
local first and then expanding
right so you have a market in that's in
new york for example right which is you
know maybe a few hundred years ago just
starting out and you had to keep an eye
on it
and then as it glow grows it becomes you
know it becomes more of an international
thing but the market physically still
resides in
new york city you can go visit it right
um
with cryptocurrencies uh you have
a market which is suddenly brand new
it's global first
it doesn't have a physical address um
and therefore
uh regulators they don't they don't
really know how to tackle it and
what what we're finding though and again
there's you know always this tug of war
that it has actually given somewhat of a
mandate
for regulators that are global in nature
which didn't really have a place until
now
are now finding it uh finding new found
power and newfound mandate
to step in and say okay now we have this
problem
so now the government in this area the
global government should get together
so in a way i mean we have for example
united nations
i have always since since being a child
have advocated for
um you know a global government right
one that kind of operates
you know and i think that that could uh
certainly do
wonders as far as you know reducing war
and poverty
um but and and maybe in this way
uh bitcoin heals the world you know what
i'm saying like
it pushes the global governments
gives them more power um and then
they can then come and and and and
i don't know join forces but again the
nice way to end this right
would you like to pick up sticks and see
how they land yeah it's a nice way to
end it could heal the world i mean
i guess you know talk about a global
government it depends you know in what
sense and in what way
um but anyway matty it's been such a
pleasure thank you so much for joining
me
um where can people find you what are
your last words just promote yourself
yeah certainly uh twitter of course and
uh come to quantum economics
dot io sign up for the newsletter
uh it's gold there you go thanks so much
everyone follow matty if you're not
already and everyone thank you so
much for tuning in i will see you next
thursday 12 p.m est bye